more Americans are waking up to the
chaotic state of democratic-run cities
and voting with their feet the top
newspaper in Oregon finally admitting
that the city's deteriorating conditions
are driving residents out they wrote
this housing unaffordability
homelessness increasing taxation drug
addiction crisis untreated mental
illness gun violence traffic deaths and
educational mediocrity are changing the
calculus for many about to where to live
raise a family or even retire other
democrat-run cities facing a similar
Exodus including Los Angeles San
Francisco Cook County Illinois that'd be
Chicago New York City and Philadelphia
there's probably other cities in there
that we haven't focused on as much
because this seems to be a phenomenon
Greg that is Nationwide yeah well in
terms of New York people are leaving
because the left emptied the prisons and
reduced the likelihood of felons serving
time so they completed half their
equation which in their altruistic world
was to have few fewer minorities in jail
but they didn't have the other half of
the equation so now you have freed
criminals and unpunished felons you know
uh free from the carceral state but now
preying on people in the neighborhoods
they're robbing they're raping they're
stabbing so we're the subject of this
experiment and I think people are
leaving because they just can't tell who
the nice people are anymore it used to
be it used to be you could go on there'd
be four kids on bicycles oh they're
gonna sell you a candy no they're going
to surround your car and they're going
to beat you that's how that's what
happened New York is now the Russian
Roulette right and this goes back to I
said it a million times uh you can't
have a one-party City especially if the
one party is a Democrat you know husband
needs a wife a bat slobby Bachelor needs
somebody to get them in shape and the
problem is there's nobody to create
friction between the Democrats and their
bad ideas somebody has to be there to
slow them down that's the wife who tells
the husband no you can't put a kiddie
pool in the basement you you know you
need somebody to stop the crazy ideas
and all the Republicans have left so all
you have are the crazy people and these
cities Geraldo are a bit in a downward
spiral and it's hard to pull out of it
once businesses start to leave your tax
base leaves and how do you get them back
I think crime is certainly an issue in
these widely publicized I mean the thing
that's changed a lot is the fact that
you see it on video so often now now you
can see actually how outrageous some of
these acts are but in my generation the
main reason people are leaving New York
for example is taxes it's not crime it's
it's like
Jesse left I left at a certain point
they're going to New Jersey they're
going to Pennsylvania going California
going to Connecticut another
democrat-run uh you know jurisdictions
they're leaving because of the finances
it's you you die in New York you pay a
death tax a city death tax a state death
tax you pay the federal death tax uh you
know why stay here go to a place where
like Florida where there's no income tax
so I think that really although crime is
definitely an issue especially when you
can see it with your with your uh with
your own eyes but I do believe that they
are when even Portland Portland when you
read The Oregonian and you talk about
what's really happening in that lovely
lovely city it's the lack of affordable
housing I think gen Z though is moving
back to the city I think the cities are
on the verge of a great Renaissance and
I tend to look at them so The Tick Tock
influencers are moving back to the city
I don't think that Portland and or L.A
or New York City are on the verge of
some great Renaissance I think it's
going to get a lot a lot worse and I'm
laughing at you Harold a little bit
because you're complaining about high
taxes which Democrats like but then you
keep voting for Democrats so all these
Democrats leave these places and then
they go to places where there are lower
taxes and they vote for the same thing
but in terms of what's Happening Here
you know the businesses are leaving all
the small businesses are closed the
corporations can afford in some places
like Walmart to relocate people but
that's not the case for everybody and
what's left is higher taxes but people
leaving so no one to pay the taxes and
then they need more money to spend on
these programs for crime and
homelessness and so where do you go from
there you go straight to the bottom and
the thing is is that if you can afford
to leave you've probably already left
the people who are left here are the
people that the left claims to stand up
for the most vulnerable the single
mothers the minimum wage workers who now
their communities have been destroyed by
these problems and they can't afford to
leave the city moving is expensive and
so they're stuck there with no real good
options not only that but Jesse there's
maybe nobody there to buy their home
well at that age you're trying to have
as much sex as possible and drink as
much as possible after college so all of
your friends you should be a real City
you move into the City and you have no
self-respect because you'll live in a
bucket and pay 900 a month but you're
meeting a lot of women and you're
drinking past midnight and you're trying
to establish a career once you get
married and have a family you move the
hell out of there geraldo's right it's
crime and covid was the one-two punch
and then you find out wait a second I'm
in Tennessee or Florida or Texas I'm
paying no state taxes I'm staying but if
I could just disagree with you slightly
I think the leadership in these cities
like the dysfunction because if they
didn't like it they'd try to clean it up
and they're almost trying to make it
worse because the more dysfunction you
have the more money you can spend on
helping people so then you raise taxes
you spend more money and you just give
it to the power Brokers who are in
charge of drugs crime and homelessness
what do they do they skim off the top
and then they plow the rest of it back
into your campaign coffers so they're
not actually trying to help the cities
they're just trying to increase their
own power remember that with the de
Blasio Administration and the
homelessness money that almost a billion
dollars and then they had to do a report
that said we we're sorry we don't know
where it went yeah we know where it went
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all year on YouTube
so subscribe right now